by the uh two of the tellers are there
that often happens what what can cause
that thing John people drop their passes
there's too much of a cue what
I I don't know to be honest because uh
I'm never allowed in the in the lobby
for during a vote I don't know if
perhaps uh if if sir Lindsay's watching
again perhaps he could text us and tell
us why that happens
um
but um it often happens in key votes
perhaps there's I don't know some
dispute I don't know
um but it does happen from time to time
and it often happens in important votes
um but it's very controversial subject
but um clearly um this is a big issue
and fracking is such a contentious issue
in so many parts of the country and uh
there's been a lot of speeches in this
debate because they had the four minute
limit on which as a political journalist
I think is a very good thing
um but it obviously enables more more
MPS to take part
um and it's it's only been a three-hour
debate because they have the earlier
opposition day debate on on the economy
earlier but one would hope I mean where
are we now we're 18 minutes past there
are unconfirmed reports that I'm getting
in my there's something happening
concerning the chief whip that is uh
Wendy Mort right well obviously we're in
the studio I don't know about that
um
but it looks like well John hold on a
minute in fact we are going to get this
result so let's listen
[Music]
order
the eyes to the right 230 the nose to
the left
326.
[Music]
thank you
the eyes to the right
230 the nose to the left
326 so the nose have it the nose have it